thank you for attending another edition
of a beginner breakdown I'm newly back
from Las Vegas I had a really excellent
time I met a lot of a lot of good people
out there a lot of intelligent people
and so I help direct the 50th national
open and have great time there with many
bets but that's all right about it I
ended with a bang so i'm i'm on fire
here so so they have me directing the
National Open and they were like what
section you want to be in what do you
think I said I said give me that you
1200 section cuz that that's where I can
get all the good material so this is a
last round game will start from the back
and go to the front so this one is a la
gracia against jennifer goodman you 1200
here alright Royals got the white pieces
so they play in the opening just fine
efore a five-night of three Knight f6
the Petrov if I was saying i'd say just
take the pollen you know free pawn and
well it's not really free because if you
take then you'll play d6 and you'll go
back and then you take and then if they
put your night in a pin right you just
get out of the pin with the Queen e7 so
that's it would be the correct rate of
play the petrol there's lots of bad ways
to play the petrol that's a good way but
anyway he plays Knight to c3 to protect
it and so he's like oh I'll protect my
pawn gets the bishop out so he gets the
bishop out ok so now white plays Knight
to g5 this is obviously not the fried
liver attack what is an excellent option
that black has in this scenario day is
not having the
why liver attack yes Julian Castle yeah
you could just castle and then if they
take you would take Bishop takes check
King takes and it's even material but
lack is ahead in development and he's
got two for one I'd much rather have two
pieces dental rook okay but instead they
pick up the wrong choice h6 attacks the
night but now the night gets the the
fork so Queen up saves the Queen but now
the rook goes so black isn't doing very
well right now so she's like I'm going
to do the same thing to you but
unfortunately it doesn't work right
because I'm white can simply capture the
night and now they're like discovered
attack you're falling right for it but
there's a very simple way to save this
Queen and the bishop okay when when you
know two things or attacked like the
Queen's attack the bishop detect that's
when if you want to save both of them
you generate an attack stronger than
your opponents so what what is the only
piece worth more than the Queen yes g6
yeah h5 is more precise but they both
get the same job done just Queen h5 as
the you 1200 player so was just a little
more accurate all right the reason why
you play Queen to h5 instead of g6 and
said because your night wants the hop to
g6 and fork the king and queen okay and
that's exactly what happened obviously
and then Knight takes Queen with check
so King takes and now you might as well
just just keep checking right now King
to f8 notice this square f 7
your queen probably wants to go there
and check mate the king but obviously
the night is here so night takes c7.r
just to be funny night to be six
whatever you want to do they take c7's
obviously better but but unfortunately
she plays the part he plays the move
check so now you're checkmate is off the
board here alright but he's like all
right I got your rook I'm going to get
another one King up so Knight takes the
other brook so to free Brooks 95 attacks
the bishop and then he's like I haven't
checked you for a move or two I'm
getting again antsy here so check and
fortunately that check wasn't the best
king of [ __ ] bright yeah it was like
there's no way she's going to see she's
obviously just gonna play there but
somehow she's like yes alright and now
this this is a so this is actually when
I started watching this game I haven't
seen anything up to here the reason why
I was so intrigued by this game is
because i saw the next move here Bishop
f7 like there's no way your Kings going
to go to e8 that's it so putting putting
your pieces you know where they can be
easily attacked in your opponent's
territory not wise so but luckily the
the game was gold up until that point so
it made all the better ok so Bishop back
to c5 so so you know night Bishop the
same rank here so you know ideas like c3
probably good but they play be three I
don't know alright so now King e7 and
Bishop back so still protecting the
precious be eight here so knight c6
black should really be in this position
ok instead of going after this Bishop
which looks tempting but it doesn't
really do anything because he easily
flees back
what piece should black be trying to
really Corral in this position yes but
Bishop d4 in this position no just play
see three put them in it's a decent idea
but look at this white knight okay its
way back on the back row not doing
anything so so you play b5 with ideas
like bishop to be seven and then that
night has no place to go okay so if if
you're your opponent has a piece way on
the back row right try to try to capture
them ok but what by playing King e7 in
this position ok it lets the night after
after this Bishop fleas and Knight to c6
it allows this night to get out so so
you got to be really precise you know if
if you know you've got a piece kind of
captured in chorale keep them corralled
ok or else if they get out they're going
to strike like kimbo right so let's look
check yeah alright so it just takes the
the bishop and boom so he resists the
urge to check here and just plays Bishop
b2 attacking the pond so now this Kings
going to go for a big walk he's going to
Castle see this King is not a warrior
right now but he's going to try to make
it a warrior I guess at I mean so you
got to ask why he made the move ok it's
true to attack here but then you have to
ask well what was the pawns job on g6 it
was protecting this point so bye-bye
pawn so King up to h6
which piece if you were playing white
would your move in this position
everybody can just shout it out at once
rook to h3 looks tempting but
unfortunately the bishop could take and
what you consolidated a lot but but we
have we have better what piece do you
think we're going to move here it's
white to move anybody got any
suggestions how about the piece that was
just attacked by the king right and so
the king is attacking the bishop so we
should move the bishop unfortunately the
bishop does not move in this position he
plays rook to f3 and so chomp just take
it okay but it's still ok for for white
even though it just lost the piece he's
up a lot of material so it's ok so now
rook f8 so she's really afraid oh my God
he's going to checkmate me when a rook 2
h8 happens which is obviously a foul so
she plays King to g6 and the bishop goes
night attacks the rook he sees it
attacks the night King up to f7 attacks
the rook so you know you piece of tack
you just move night attacks the rook
rook takes check night here now
everybody should know exactly what white
should play in this position right yeah
right yeah we don't even have to say it
right attack the pin pieces how hard is
it right but unfortunately it can't
resist the pawn now night attacks the
rook again Brooke Chuck and now this
time he takes here King backup and d4
okay so now you tax the bishop so Bishop
fleas all the way back all right night
attacks the rook big check knight c6 ok
so now why do you think she played that
move she knows it's obviously suicide
but she's trying to achieve the
stalemate position in this in this uh in
this break so now he's portions upon
she's pushing King up King attacks the
rook rook here King there and now at
this point in the game who do you think
is more upset when the sin at the board
the player with the white pieces of
player with the black pieces it's a
trick question the guy playing white uh
where well he's just he's grown and he's
like oh oh it's so tough if you had this
position on the board you should be like
I love it okay I'm just gonna I just got
to march my pawns up and just get a
queen and I just check meet you right
you shouldn't be moaning and groaning
the girl playing black has every right
to to try and go for it you know a
stalemate she's under no obligation to
make life easy for you and resign it
will in reality life is easy you're up
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 to nothing
you're up by three touchdowns and you
have a possibility to get all eight
Queens promote all pond so so you should
relish this situation that oh and so
check and so Brooke back so all he has
to do obviously is play bump bump and
he's got made in like four right instead
well there goes so so let's see how long
it takes them to get a queen from this
position alright so so King there so so
it's smart not to get a queen here
alright so rook up King up now you could
promote the poem with check what's
stopping you from doing that I don't
know
haha now you can protect the rook if you
promoted rook back alright so now you
can't permit of humor you blew your
chance alright so now he protects it so
she should obviously block at least try
but she goes there and now he can't
resist the get the check up that check
that forward you you thought you he was
going to get that one alright so so now
I get push that one a minute King here
why in n games just just get it and get
it done okay we don't need all this
theatrics moaning the groaning and the
stalling all right now he's like or am
sick of fooling around and now he does
find the mate here where is the
checkmate
nope Rick a five does not work because
that would allow me to go to be 40 Queen
850 queening fun they stopped early but
Queen 85 gets the job done as well so
you had a lot of meats all right so when
you finally finally figured it out here
alright so now we're going to go to the
start of the tournament board one under
1,200 so if you're afraid to like in a
tournament and like oh my god I'm
playing the top guy on board one okay so
let's see he might win actually this
gentleman is from Missouri as well the
only a couple of Missouri guys I saw out
in Vegas here okay so white starts out
he's he's the number one seed bearing
with white he's playing Charles nice guy
efore c69 f3e 6d four so so White's
winning here Black's going to try to
break it open but but White's like
there's no way I'm going to trade and
let your bishop out so he plays 'if I've
good for him 97 here Bishop attacks the
Queen Bishop blocks it he protects it
with the pawn and black plays h6 so so
they got it he's got to take and take so
now so now if you were playing white I
give you a hint which piece would you
probably get out the bishop the other
night or the queen or the rook okay so
those are four options you can move the
rook off the back row the bishop off the
back row the Queen off the back row or
the night which one you like
alright he's just like I don't like any
of them i'm going to play see three all
right so so if i was playing i would
definitely get my bishop out right a
fortunate he plays queen to d3 here it
doesn't help with counseling it doesn't
help with anything so now the difference
between whites move and blacks move is
this boob actually attacks something
right so so that's why the idea of c3
prowling the position was pretty good
because then you can play Queen c2 and
Bishop the d3 to them alright so 23
happened Queen B 6 attacks the pun so
let's see how he protects it he protects
it with the pawn ponds are the best at
protecting other pawns obviously all
right a 6 now the bishop is relegated to
just doing nothing on e to c5 protect it
does not get the CC 60 so blacks finally
of getting getting again some pieces
going sure thing
oh just just charge up c4 yeah I mean so
he'll take that most likely and then you
want to take what the night I guess or
do you want to trade queens oh yeah
Knight takes here yup so so yeah
sometimes it's better just they attack
your pawn just deal with the situation
at hand you know either take it or
protect it or move it forward but try
not to ignore it okay so so night up d
for take c5 and now the night captures
and attacks the Queen so Queen III puts
the night in a temporary pin here but
then I can flee to here and protect but
he plays a unorthodox move here places
Queen back to a 7 so white attacks with
be four black plays Knight a for now
okay he plays Queen f4 so you think
there might be a trick here but there's
not let's say Charles just castles here
okay and then they play b5 ok so I'm
attacking this night and simultaneously
attacking this night should I care the
answer is no because I can just capture
this pawn and Queen takes Knight is off
the table and obviously pawn takes
Knight us off the table so instead he
gets worried about this and plays b5
himself
okay so so b5 happens and so now white
gets castled and black plays Bishop
piece of it let me ask you a question
here if who do you think's going to get
checked first in this game the guy with
the beautiful castle he's got three guys
defending before with the rook all on
his King side are the guy you know king
in the center you would probably think
black might have a chance to get checked
here eventually but White's going to
make it easy for him to get checked
after Bishop e7 white decides to push
his pawns in front of his King very
unorthodox so rook the c8 so now black
cannot castle over there and he's just
going to keep his charge going Knight
takes so so now there's an obvious
threat Queen takes f7 chuck it might be
kind of scary the castle over here now
because I might try this this and this
so i don't think i would castle for
black here so he plays a really funny
move to protect this pawn bishop 2a8
nothing wrong with that so discovered
protection rook to see one queen e 7 a-3
and now he could put his Bishop back to
be set but that really should have been
a priority okay the priority should have
been you know trying to diminish this
attack Queen g3 now he complicates thing
with d4 so instead of really addressing
that the situation he just
plays a place night up so he's like okay
I'm going to take it then and as I'm
going to take this now this this is a
very very risky thing to do right
because you got the Queen and the king
on the exact same line here obviously in
this position I would probably play king
here even though I get checked it's okay
because I'm going to go here and now my
threat is rook g8 all right let's see
what he ends up doing he ends up
offering a trade of Queens and kind of
letting him off the hook here but he
doesn't want to and now he's like all
right fine you had your chance now I'm
going to get stuck checks Rick g8 king
over and I was like you sure you don't
want to trade and it's like yeah I'm
sure I don't care you can go ahead and
check me on g2 that's fine whatever and
so it's like all right I'll do it then
I'll do it kingi one and so now another
check here so he's only got one way the
real well yeah only one way I mean you
can take what go back with the night
obviously but so Bishop f1 here so what
well so let's see what we got here all
right so you want to open up the lines
here and so just move the night anywhere
maybe even that takes before words the
best but whatever night e 7 ok so now
all he's got to do is get get down there
and he should be winning here so here we
go night
g5 threatening his own check here okay
so so can we get away with Bishop 2g to
hear this is when we really have to
calculate luckily we have a kibitz ER
here that will tell us everything but
I'm thinking we don't have to calculate
let's just play Bishop g2 am Bishop g2
would probably lose horribly huh yeah
that gives us a slight edge but it is
like okay I place them up prevent
defense here or control two or something
oh I'm learning I'm learning I'm
learning so so the guy under 1,200 he
must have been sitting there using all
his time and and really calculated out
okay Bishop g2 I can't do it I gotta
play Knight f5 something like that okay
so so night f5 here and so it now it's
like I'm going for it so now he's got to
calculate some more again and be like
can I get away with Bishop the g two are
what about work the g one already now
you got to just do it right you gotta do
it yeah yeah Rick g1 it's a winner yeah
that's a winner alright so work to you
one and you just did check me on f6 I
don't care all right but he's like nope
nope Rick g7 and that doesn't even if
you're going to move the rock you might
as well move them all the way down but
now check happens King e7 now he's like
I don't care about any of that stuff i'm
just going to take your pole and it's
like all right well good luck with this
and it's like I can't resist taking your
night I gets Queen down to d2
threatening check
so now he's he's so afraid of everything
look so Queen c6 it's always like and
even though you're scared and making
defensive moves doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to stop the attack either
okay so let's see how this plays out
here so so Bishop he decides I'm going
to distract the Queen mama from c6 all
right how should black obviously respond
to this will take the bishop with who
well we'll see that's what he thought
whatever I'll God just take the bishop
with the Queen it doesn't matter let's
see if it matters Julian let's see if it
matters rook takes the night and now he
can't resist playing some more defense
night e 7 rook takes rook check
Bishop takes and now can anybody see a
mate I give you a hint you only have
four checks two of them work as the help
oh yeah he's got it Queen to e8 you know
you are d 8 but it's good to get right
in his grill here alright so that was
bored one and so let's see how how the
the gentleman does on his next game ok
done the favorite the number one seed
Barry ok so Barry has the black pieces
in this round two so let's see if his
reign on board one can blast it all
right so why place efore b5 night of
three nights c6 d4 let's just take it
Bishop c4 max defense again so all these
guys so obviously free pawn you can't do
it cuz of rookie one just like in that
last game when he broke open that G file
all right so he's like I'm not taking it
on that like that so it's like I'm gonna
attack your bishop see what you think
about that it's like I see it ok alright
so now now Bishop e7 c3 trying to break
it open it's like okay I was just
portion it's like fine it's mine oh I
probably want to get some of my pieces
off the back row but I can't resist
attacking that [ __ ] up one more time
yeah hey rookie one Knight to e5 all
right so he's going to stop a five by
putting something on it so Knight takes
Queen takes Queen c4 attacks f seven
here alright what how is the whenever
somebody's trying to do the four move
checkmate or whatever on you you know
where where he's got the Queen and the
bishop all in a battery both pounded
down on f7 the obviously worse way to
protect this that's not what you think
i'm going to say f6 there's even
something worse well they're closed is a
very close night to h6 who is Chris now
he's he's operating as a defender right
but he can easily be captured and
removed from the game and in this
position you have to take here because
you're not kid can't be down a piece
even though it allows it you still might
have a chance yeah but so after that
after Bishop takes h6 that is like dawn
so what does he bore does he play here
Queen h5 so protects and attacks the
bishop so so my big question to him
would be why did you just play Queen age
five in the first place but but I never
got to ask him the question alright so
now so now Bishop takes g7 he's like I
don't care alright so now this getting
scary again alright so here we go so
Bishop the d4 all right not if you
really wanted the thread checkmate in
this position which piece would you use
anybody have any guesses who's the most
powerful piece the Queen you can do all
kinds of cool stuff you can play your
queen there put your queen there put
your queen there put your queen there
put your queen there you get the point
hope you would I put them here well I
don't know where you would put them but
obviously he's like
yeah and I got threaten checkmate but
i'll throw in a devastating check and so
he's like Boop alright so now he's like
now this guy's like always a move behind
okay so that was like all right now
threatened to checkmate I'm so cool and
then he's like pontic and I was like
calling over his family look look at me
look at me checkmate what I can't do
checkmate no cuz you yourself are in
check and guess what move you have to
make that Queenie to ya hear out so so
fortunately so if you touch a piece and
even though you weren't intending to put
it there you can make a legal move with
it you have to do it in this position he
actually goes to e4 and you know you
don't have to take the Queen now he
plays Queen takes f7 check King d8
Bishop f6 looks pretty good but it can't
resist taking the rook and then it's a
it's all over rook takes Queen checkmate
alright so we got a now we'll see if the
guy that lost in the first round of the
number one seed can redeem himself in
round two this time Charles has the
white pieces starts out d 4 counters
with d5 that Queens gambit accepted he
takes it so in this position should play
either Knight c3 or e 4 to try to corral
the pawn back nine up three is the best
move no way geez look up look at you
think III is the best move in this
position as well no all right all right
so he tries to protect the pawn here
beef I Bishop e2 get this Bishop Finn
kiddo so a three by a four was what he
was really going for a schlep yeah yeah
yeah so all right so after Bishop e7
here now he gets this night out attacks
the poem so it protects it with a six
white gets castle at d7 brookie one now
now now if you were playing as black
here what do you think your priority
should be in this position
not do you don't want you don't want you
don't play Knight f6 and none of a
bright right so so so okay so Rick is on
the same Lane as the King so e6 very
risky so II for so let's get one more
dude in that lane with the King okay
crazy seven so you don't really want to
be playing like this because I think d5
here might be devastating let's check it
out we could get even get greedy right
it actually likes beef I what does a
computer now all right so so Bishop
attacks the poem so he decides to
protect it with the king so castle the
King would have been a lot safer well
before with the pond still on e seven
with nine f6 and castle and now it's as
anybody's game over here so Queen c2
gets a gets a queen on the same Lane as
the King again and so so now as we saw
it in that first game and in fact with
the one where the guy beat them you know
he moved up all his Kings pawns so I
guess he saw that it worked for him
somehow it's gotta work for me so C 581
so training you want your king like this
guy's King you know everybody's safe and
protecting them and you can't get
checked and life is good for him I work
a 2d one so so takes d4
Knight takes d4 and now he gets pawn for
it so he can't make a threat greater or
equal to this pawn fork unfortunately so
all I can do is try to get upon for it
and that's what he does Bishop e3 Bishop
protects the pawn here night attacks the
Queen so he's like okay I'm just going
to take take but now who r if you take
with the rook keep keep it open is there
any way that we can protect this pawn
and the answer is 0 probably not well
not that I can see so he plays Knight
the v8 excuse me he plays Queen to e8 so
when he takes here now he set up a
discovered attack i'm hookin but but now
his his whole queenside castle is now
destroyed Queen takes e4 so so if he was
going to block with the Queen don't
shout it out too fast cuz my first my
first inclination was wrong yep but then
two seconds later I found the right move
so so look we've been talking about you
know king queen in the same line so this
looks pretty tempting this is why they
always say you see a good move look more
look for a better room right because we
can remove the defender of the dude and
so if even if he tries to protect this
like you're not taking my queen oh I
didn't even see that rookie one check
and then yeah yeah alright Julian's
better
yeah and then we win it all okay so so
so obviously I mean he plays Knight to
c6 anyway what up so now everybody
should know what the right answer is
here now yeah just pile up on the pin
piece so he protects it give them a big
check and now rook the d1 see if it
works King protects the rook when you're
using your king as a main protector of
pieces and he's in the center and he's
going to check you're not doing very
well just so you know all right so rook
takes d6 obviously King takes another
check Bishop to b5 well he's going to
play that after he gets a check in yeah
well so that's what he does ok now he
gets try to attack him some more so now
he gets a great defensive move finally
gets the night finally in the game where
it should have been on move up whatever
10 all right so now he has to retreat
all the way back and so now obviously
you can't resist the urge playoff 66 I
always resist the urge ok and and now
he's toast right all because he had to
play up six check is there any way to
get out of this check only one night to
d5 just take it
not and now with the pawn I was thinking
about it but Bishop takes d5 kingi 7
Bishop the c5 check King d7 you think
White's moaning and groaning like that
guy we saw earlier bro I'm up so much
why is my guy resigning no he's happy
he's just like give me it just give me
this is this time of my life right now
take e8 rook takes e8 check king be
seven and now he just can't everything
sport so he can't take it anymore so
he's like he throws in the towel he
throws in the towel and so that's that
was the National Open under 1,200 sold
so you know if you're afraid are you
thinking like oh man am I really good
enough to play like you know maybe you
have a rating of 600 or something but
you've been watching the videos getting
better playing on chest calm or the ICC
you know it's not it's not that tough
you just your opponents will make bad
moves and you just got to be there to
capitalize on it when when you got the
got the shot okay so okay that's a
beginner breakdown Vegas edition a glad
you enjoyed it
you